on dise youn et le versement du rsa à
des heures de bénévolat dispositif
imaginé par l'ancien président du
conseil départemental du haut rhin eric
straumann retoqué par le tribunal
administratif de strasbourg il a donc
depuis évolué et se basent maintenant
sur le volontariat et en quatre mois 500
bénéficiaires se sont portés candidats
donc département nadine lit dans son
enyele alors je vous explique les
enfants alors nous avons ici une petite
roulette christelle brandon burget est
devenu une figure incontournable de la
ludothèque de saint louis
c'est elle qui anime chaque mercredi les
ateliers d enfance quatre heures de
bénévolat par semaine depuis septembre
un engagement que christelle
bénéficiaires du rsa a voulu est choisi
pour moi est un tremplin professionnel
on remet tout ce que ça m'a apporté en
bien-être bien sûr de l'assurance aussi
sam interne est vraiment de d'apprendre
à gérer les groupes d'enfants
ça m'a conforté aussi dans mes choix
le bénévolat conçu comme un moyen
d'insertion professionnelle c'est
l'objectif de ce nouveau dispositif mis
en place en septembre par le conseil
départemental
plus question d'imposer des heures de
bénévolat aux bénéficiaires du rsa comme
cela avait été envisagé au départ
on n'est plus du tout sur le rsa contre
bénévolat c'est vraiment un dispositif
rsa et bénévolat et bénévolat comme
levier d'insertion complémentaires il
est proposé à la locataire dans le cadre
du travail sur son projet par son
référent
dès lors que ça représente un plus pour
pour lui alors bon on est vraiment sur
le lit des deux être actif c'est positif
comme christelle ils sont 500
bénéficiaires du rsa à s'être porté
volontaire cette année et les offres ne
manquent pas recette 100 propositions
sont disponibles est visible sur le site
du conseil départemental
une aubaine pour les associations et les
collectivités en mal de moyens et
d'effectifs
nous on a tout de suite vu une
opportunité disons pour aider aussi ces
personnes qui sont en difficulté et
également donc nous collectivités à
pouvoir bénéficier de compétences de
personnes
qui ne serait peut-être pas venu chez
nous autrement l'objectif final reste de
décrocher un emploi un vrai christelle
est sur la bonne voie grâce à ses heures
de bénévolat elle a déjà signé un petit
contrat d'encadrement dans une école une
première est indispensable victoire